[Música]
el presidente de eeuu joe biden a
abandono israelí ya fue recibido por el
príncipe mohammed bin salman de arabia
saudita en el palacio real en medio de
su gira por medio oriente una visita
llena de controversias por sus posturas
pasadas sobre los derechos humanos en el
reino y relacionadas con la muerte del
periodista alfa show
europa sufre una nueva e inusual ola de
calor que aumenta la cantidad de
incendios registrados hasta la fecha en
el continente los primeros 10 días de
julio la cifra de hectáreas quemadas
triplica la media registrada en este
periodo entre 2008 y 2020
panamá vive su peor ola de protestas en
tres décadas la decisión del presidente
de laurentino cortizo de congelar los
precios de los combustibles no
desactivan el descontento social
mientras crece la expectativa por el
diálogo entre el gobierno y los
representantes de la manifestación
hablamos con uno de los líderes de las
protestas
bienvenidos al nuevo informativo de
france 24 sé rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos el presidente de eeuu
joe biden ya se encuentra en arabia
saudita en medio de su gira por medio
oriente allí fue recibido por el
príncipe mohammed bin salman en el
palacio real tras su viaje desde israel
según la oficina de baile en el
presidente no rehuirá tratar con las
autoridades sauditas temas como la
violación de los derechos humanos en el
reyno o el asesinato del periodista
jamal ja sobre nuestro corresponsal en
jerusalén federico cue barberena tiene
más detalles
recalibrar las relaciones es el lema
elegido por el gobierno de joe biden
para justificar el controvertido viaje
del presidente estadounidense a arabia
saudita en campaña by the navy ha
prometido tratar al reyno de paria pero
el contexto global con altos precios del
petróleo y la inflación disparada
llevaron a un cambio de discurso en las
reuniones con el rey salman y el
príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman
baiden según sus asesores no evitará
abordar el respeto a los derechos
humanos en medio de las críticas por el
asesinato en 2018 del periodista jobs y
del que nacía acusa a la corona saudita
by the end además va a participar de una
cumbre con los líderes de arabia saudita
emiratos árabes unidos bahrein kuwait
qatar omán egipto jordania e iraq allí
se espera que el presidente
estadounidense discuta sobre de
seguridad energética y pida un aumento
de la producción de petróleo para
reducir los precios aunque la casa
blanca no espera que eso ocurra en los
inmediatos maiden también pretende
destacar la presencia de eeuu en medio
oriente para no dejar un vacío que
pudieran llenar naciones como china
rusia o irán en esta estrategia incluida
israel es clave para eeuu y ya logró un
primer paso luego de que rían abriera en
espacio aéreo a vuelos desde y hacia
israel otro posible acuerdo sería
permitir viajes directos entre israel y
arabia saudita para peregrinos
musulmanes mientras que el gobierno
israelí aprobó un plan para que dos
islas del mar rojo pasen de egipto a
control saudita bajo garantías de
mantener la libre navegación con eso se
logró se espera irse de bailén de medio
oriente aunque sabiendo que una
normalización total de relaciones entre
israel y arabia saudita es un proceso
más complejo y que no en el corto plazo
joe biden estuvo previamente en velen
para una reunión con el presidente de la
autoridad nacional palestina mahmud
abbas tras reunirse con los líderes
israelíes ayer el presidente de eeuu se
declaró amigo de los palestinos y
reiteró la unión americana está
comprometida con una solución de dos
estados al conflicto con israel si bien
reconoció que no hay condiciones para
las negociaciones
además anunció ayudas por más de 100
millones de dólares para los hospitales
de la zona escuchemos parte de las
declaraciones de bailén
este nombre el pueblo palestino se
merece un estado que sea independiente
soberano viable y contiguo dos estados
para dos pueblos ambos tienen raíces
profundas en esta tierra viviendo lado a
lado
e incluso si el terreno no está
preparado en este momento para
restablecer las negociaciones eeuu y mi
administración no se rendirán para
tratar de traer a los palestinos ya los
israelíes a ambos bandos más cerca y
unidos vamos ahora con noticias de la
guerra en ucrania porque el presidente
de volodymyr selenski pidió reconocer a
rusia como estado terrorista tras el
ataque el jueves contra la ciudad de
inicia este acto dejó al menos 23
muertos y ucrania asegura que golpeó un
centro cultural utilizado por veteranos
retirados selenski agregó que existe la
necesidad urgente de crear un tribunal
especial sobre la agresión rusa a su
país rusia sin embargo se defiende
alegando que el ataque estaba dirigido a
un edificio en que los altos cargos de
las fuerzas armadas de ucrania se
reunían con proveedores de armas
extranjeros
las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa continúan su operación militar
especial en ucrania misiles calibre de
alta precisión con base en el mar
alcanzaron un edificio en la guarnición
de la casa de oficiales a la ciudad de
milicia en el momento del ataque se
estaba celebrando en esta instalación
militar una reunión entre el mando de
las fuerzas aéreas de ucrania y los
representantes de los proveedores de
armas extranjeros
vamos a esta italia donde el ejecutivo
sufre una crisis política mario draghi
seguirá siendo el primer ministro al
menos hasta el próximo miércoles cuando
acuda al parlamento para verificar si
cuenta con la mayoría suficiente
draghi cuya dimisión fue rechazada ayer
jueves por el jefe del estado sergio
mataré la comunicará entonces si está
dispuesto a continuar al frente del
ejecutivo desde roma a natalia mendoza
no se amplía la inestabilidad política
amenaza una vez más a italia después de
que el jefe del gobierno italiano mario
draghi presentó este jueves su dimisión
al presidente italiano sergio matar el a
este último no aceptó la renuncia de
draghi y le solicitó que de encontrar
una nueva mayoría en el parlamento
italiano que le permita continuar con su
mandato detrás de bambalinas las
negociaciones entre fuerzas políticas
italianas no han parado si no logran en
llegar a un acuerdo con mario draghi el
presidente italiano matare la podría
nombrar otro primer ministro o también
convocar elecciones anticipadas en
italia hipótesis que hacen temer una
crisis política que cae en un muy mal
momento para el país sometido a fuertes
presiones económicas a causa de la
inflación la plan demia y una crisis
energética consecuencia del bloqueo del
gas ruso a europa para tratar de salir
de este laberinto político mario draghi
pronunciara un discurso ante el
parlamento italiano el próximo miércoles
día en el cual se valorará si el actual
gobierno dispone de una mayoría en el
parlamento que le permita seguir en pie
seguimos en europa y nos centramos en la
ola de calor que está sufriendo buena
parte del continente especialmente los
países del sur europeo ante este
episodio que romperá récords de
temperaturas máximas la organización
meteorológica mundial advirtió del
riesgo que corren las personas más
vulnerables también por la degradación
de la calidad del aire y
cabe señalar que la alta temperatura no
es la única consecuencia adversa de las
olas de calor la atmósfera estable y
estancada actúa como una tapa para
atrapar los contaminantes atmosféricos
incluidas las partículas aumentando su
concentración más cerca de la superficie
esto da como resultado la degradación de
la calidad del aire y efectos adversos
para la salud particularmente para las
personas vulnerables un bulbo pipo
durante los primeros 10 días de julio
los incendios arrasaron unas 250.000
hectáreas de territorio de la unión
europea una cifra que triplica la media
registrada en este periodo entre 2008 y
2020 los países del sur del continente
son también los que más están sufriendo
estas precoces y extremas olas de calor
que alimentan y descontrolan los
incendios forestales en francia los
fuegos en el suroeste y en el sureste
del hexágono devastan preciados
patrimonios naturales como los bosques
del departamento de la gigante y del
bard
desde el add-on de pila en la costa
atlántica de francia una devastadora
perspectiva humo negro en el horizonte
los incendios arrasan los bosques del
suroeste del país este jueves los
bomberos evacuaron a los vecinos de las
áreas amenazadas
miles de personas han tenido que
abandonar la zona de media vuelta
no es que estemos muy nerviosas pero es
un fastidio para nosotros porque
estábamos hospedadas allí y no tenemos
nada que ver evacuaciones puerta por
puerta frente a vecinos a veces
reticentes a abandonar sus hogares
señora hay que evacuar por el humo señor
tiene que irse ya ya pero yo me quedo
aquí no puede ser tiene que irse me da
igual yo me quedo aquí ustedes tampoco
se quieren ir bueno así que tiene una
máscara de gas qué quiere que le diga
en un contexto de fuertes y cada vez más
recurrentes olas de calor
11 departamentos franceses están en
alerta naranja el sureste la costa
mediterránea también arde los bomberos
intentan contener un incendio declarado
este jueves de momento no afecta a
ninguna residencia sin embargo las
autoridades temen que un cambio en el
viento este viernes reavive las llamas y
complique la extinción del fuego en la
que está siendo una temporada de
incendios
excepcionalmente precoz y devastadora
tras más de una semana de protestas y
bloqueos se instaló en panamá una mesa
de diálogo entre el gobierno y algunos
representantes de las manifestaciones
con miras a desactivar la crisis que
inició como una protesta en contra del
alza del precio del combustible y que ya
se transformó en un reclamo general por
igualdad social desde ciudad de panamá
saúl méndez secretario general del
sindicato único nacional de trabajadores
de la industria de la construcción nos
habló previamente de las causas de la
protesta y de sus pedidos al gobierno
lo primero que hay que decir es que vivo
una crisis como el resto de nuestro
planeta y especial américa latina y el
caribe
acumulada de neoliberalismo que ha
excluido panamá es el quinto país en el
mundo segundo en américa latina' la peor
distribución de riqueza en un país pobre
un país con muchos recursos pero que
quedan en 115 ultramillonario más de 20
mil millones de dólares los problemas
que estamos viviendo a la alza del
combustible
comida medicamentos
electrificación no son producto de la
guerra en ucrania es una constante de 32
años de implementación de política
económica no liberal pura y dura de 7
gobiernos en panamá 7 asambleas de
diputados que ha impuesto estas
condiciones de vida en realidad la
pandemia y la guerra pusieron como la
cereza en el pastel y este estallido
realmente está demandando cosas
inmediatas como una disminución del
precio del combustible alimentos
medicamentos
electrificación aumento general de
salarios nación para poder darle poder
adquisitivo y seguir discutiendo el
resto de los puntos que presentamos que
fueron 32 a través de la alianza pueblo
unido y que el gobierno no ha querido
sentarse con los actores que están en
lucha el gobierno ayer llamó una reunión
estilo feria un mercado persa donde
llamó a raimundo y todo el mundo hay
menos a lo que estamos en lucha entonces
en un conflicto deben estar son las
partes sentadas
vamos hasta perú en donde por primera
vez en la historia del país la corte
suprema autorizó una eutanasia el fallo
dictado el jueves permite a la psicóloga
anna estrada el acceso a una muerte
asistida a la mujer padece una
enfermedad degenerativa e incurable el
fallo será tras una demanda de amparo de
la defensoría del pueblo y ratifica otra
sentencia anterior de la justicia
peruana sobre el mismo caso en 2021 el
próximo 22 de julio una jueza resolverá
el protocolo médico para llevar a cabo
el procedimiento
el presidente del parlamento de sri
lanka anunció temprano este viernes que
había aceptado la dimisión por correo
electrónico del presidente gotabaya
rajapaksa un día después de que huyera
al exilio en singapur los manifestantes
se retiraron de los edificios públicos
que ocupaban desde hace algunos días
pero prometieron seguir luchando para
que el primer ministro nombrado como
presidente interino también dimita
escenas de gozo en la capital decir
blanca en las calles de colombo cientos
de personas celebraron la dimisión del
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa
bueno hay un espíritu festivo en este
momento creo que la gente aquí está muy
contenta con esta decisión y das
una salida confirmada del viernes por la
mañana por el parlamento de es blanca la
carta de dimisión del presidente
rajapaksa enviada por correo electrónico
tras su llegada a singapur ha sido
validada
he recibido la dimisión del presidente
gotabaya rajapaksa de acuerdo con el
artículo 38 1 de la constitución de la
república socialista democrática decir
lanka en consecuencia el presidente ha
renunciado legalmente a la presidencia
la asimilé
el primer ministro rango y créeme singer
es ahora el presidente en funciones
según la constitución el parlamento
tiene 30 días para nombrar a su sucesor
los diputados lo elegirán en los
próximos siete días
el tiempo se acaba sri lanka atraviesa
actualmente una grave crisis económica
la isla se enfrenta a cortes de
electricidad escasez de combustible
escasez de alimentos y una inflación
récord para salir de la crisis una
solución desbloquear las negociaciones
con el fondo monetario internacional y
obtener un plan de rescate
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a france 24 y recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta hay mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]